what is up reject nation we're gonna
watch from easily one of the
great if you have not subscribed to this
guy i sincerely mean it i went back and
forth with someone i was like
seriously let me explain to you why this
guy is so great it had
he had nothing to do with our video but
i was like i got to do it with someone
mr creptious spider-man homeworld's
concept trailer wonder woman 1984
style i didn't know it was going to be
in the style of this but he did tease
that he's going to be doing a spider-man
3 concept trailer
since we haven't even gone to the
trailer yet it probably won't for a
while look
if you haven't seen any of his videos i
already know this is going to be awesome
i already know i'm going to be like
i hope the movie feels this good got my
reactions mapped out i'm just saying
john that this might be supplementary
for a while until we get the actual
trailer i'll take it all right
i'll take it
i love using the voiceover i'm sorry
you're saying that you're multiverse
now we understand the initial
singularity we're talking about an
internal inflation system and how does
that even work with all the quantum
slipped it right in there
us that keeps us honest gives us
strength
makes us noble hold on to hope
ladies and fasten your gentlemen belts
so cool
[Music]
oh my god
bring it
dude you [ __ ] did it hopes
will collide seems like superhero kind
of stuff
[Music]
yeah i met him in there
that was that was amazing i wanted to
see what i mean guys
yeah like i had no idea what this is
gonna be and he managed to like
i'm like damn it felt so real you
slipped in characters that we've been
anticipating but i wasn't in the moment
expecting to see and it was like such
it for a minute tricks your mind or my
mind into thinking like oh man this is
actually real like i actually got caught
up in there i know he got the doc och in
there he got the daredevil obviously
some doctor strange all the things that
have been gay like green goblin
everything that's been getting teased he
threw it all into this one trailer but
what i love is like how he does the
color correction and such to make it
really feel like it's all blended within
the same world
but this was so exciting this to me is
such ultimate fan fulfillment everything
that we've been hearing with the teases
of spider-man 3
what's going to be in it what it might
be like we don't really know yet what
it's going to ultimately feel like
this is so in alignment with what our i
think are
for those who are looking forward to it
what our imaginations have been leading
us down
absolutely is this kind of vibe this
kind of enthusiasm and excitement
and pulse-pounding exhilarating action
and crosses the world oh crap just
give me orgasms with the way you
assemble these man they're so impressive
like you need to be you need to be
cutting the real trailers
you should be yeah because the other
thing too and i didn't ever think that
you know these wouldn't
mesh well together but you know being
that you're drawing from
well over a decades worth of movies to
put this together
i liked how everything really did seem
to fit together really nicely and even
characters like
most of the talks but about toby maguire
but i even got excited
to see andrew garfield yeah who has like
been part of these talks but i feel like
he's not
the big thing people are excited for but
that got me further anticipating how
much better this could
you know if it is a success and not a
bloated mess make
the previous installments even that
didn't fully get their
due or whatever and starting with one
yeah
and starting with the ancient one i just
love that uh touch of taking that
end game monologue and tying it into
everything and then also
like into the spider verse and having to
be called the collider that machine that
opens up the multiverse so it kind of
feels like a double play with saying
worlds will collide because you know
we've heard that tagline before but it
means more when you're doing kind of
this multiverse spider-man movie
you know i don't even know if that was
intentional or not you know you could
pull from that
i just have no idea how you do it this
is so much work
because even like at the very beginning
you do see like andrew garfield and then
they do have
the doctor not forgetting the name of
this specific thing the doctor
strange little hole the portal the
portal appear
throwing that in there for amazing
spider-man but literally if you go every
three to five seconds there's a
different shot in here and so it has to
be so
incredibly mapped out to know how you're
gonna put this one together and then
also
putting it in sync with the music and we
didn't even talk about the fact that
it's not just riffing solely on using
the wonder woman 1984 blue monday song
you're also
liking the whole trailer to the style of
the wonder woman
not even thinking about that part it
feels like way more than that having to
script this
out and then the amount of footage you
have to go through
it really feels like you're combing
through every single second of these
movies to try to mat like what does your
bedroom look like
what is your opponent
looks like a peter parker room yeah
racks of screens
everywhere and i mean like yeah i was
sitting here wondering too like how do
you decide
a which clips to put in which order and
b which clips to alter
further because that's that's another
thing is like there's some stuff that
you get to work together that just
blends already but certain other things
yeah like you mentioned with the portal
or later on
with doc ock where you can see like into
the multiverse through what he's working
on
or even uh when spider-man and daredevil
look at each other in the second time
and this trailer where it looks like the
same kind of flame background is
happening for both of them
littlest things when doctors doctor
strange
says he's in the hall and then they cut
to the shot which is from amazing
spider-man 2 i believe when he's looking
up at harry osborne yeah
but it matches it looks like it's from
the same scene yeah and then you threw
your own little trailer ding
button in there just to put your own
stank on it yeah i appreciate it yeah
i mean if he had more like morbius
footage to work off of i'm sure he could
have figured out some way to even throw
morbius in there there's something we
can finally complain about where was
morgan where was
he got venom in there you got everybody
got rhino and actually that
that sinister six shot i thought was
really great showing all the different
again it's like piecing them together
from the different movies and yet i was
like damn
i would like to see this ensemble and
sinister and guys he also let's not
forget
i believe he changed electro to be
yellow oh
snap instead of blue you're a wizard
you've been paying attention
to all the reports in the news and then
you brought it to life here that's
that's what i think is so impressive
about it is he brought to life a lot of
what has been reported on already or
speculated about
so dude mr crutches you're the man
you really are the man christian
reptious making wishes come true one
trailer cut at a time
follow this guy follow him
he paid us a thousand dollars to cover
this video right i thought it was okay
i hated it i don't i don't like chris
trailers
generally discover anybody i don't like
trailers even give them like
movies or anything
spider-man sucks i hate dc agreed
mm-hmm all right guys
jokes [ __ ] you never know people in
other countries who watch our videos
coffee can't pick up
no spider-man's not a dc character all
right subscribe click that notification
bell hit that like button we'll see you
guys soon